to do one a I haven't been here in a
while she's back I was gonna say so many
things are not normal and in this moment
right now as I'm looking at you
something finally is it's good to see
your face Savannah Guthrie returned to
the Today Show on Tuesday joining her
co-host Toto Kotb but making sure to
keep 6 feet away Savannah had been
co-hosting the show from home for almost
two weeks as she self quarantined due to
the corona virus pandemic practicing our
social distancing it's good to be back
in the studio
Savannah celebrated her return on
Instagram posting this sweet selfie with
Hoda
alongside the caption reunited the sweet
reunion comes nearly a week after Hoda
broke down in tears after an interview
with NFL Pro Drew Brees who donated five
million dollars to Louisiana coronavirus
relief of course Brees is a longtime
quarterback for the New Orleans Saints
Hoda who used to live in the Big Easy is
a huge fan I also think a lot of things
are contagious including generosity so
our hope is is that because you know you
let us know that you made this big
generous donation I think other people
look and say hey maybe I can help out
too
Hoda did her best to fight back tears
that's when Savannah attempted to
comfort Hoda live on air from home it's
a lot I know where your heart is my dear
I do how about I read the tease ok ok
deep breath later in the show Hoda and
Savannah opened up about her emotional
moment I think the other thing too is
you sort of look around for someone to
hug just because and you realize ok yeah
that's that's also part of it but anyway
the new normal if we get used to it
right yes and it's not forever yes I'm
gonna be awkward
hugging you you're gonna be like get off
me savanah you're a creep get out of
here and I'm not gonna stop hugging you
[Music]